mesdames et messieurs bonjour ici céline
galipeau à montréal bienvenue à cette
émission spéciale du jour du souvenir en
hommage aux soldats canadiens disparus
alors vous voyez des images qui nous
parviennent en direct de la foulée des
anciens combattants réunis au monument
commémoratif de guerre à quelques pas de
la colline parlementaire au centre-ville
d'ottawa
le temps est nuageux il fait moins cinq
degrés ce matin pas facile pour les
vétérans qui se sont installés ou qui
s'apprête à s'installer vous les voyez
marché la très dignement fièrement avec
leurs médailles pour saluer une fois
encore leurs camarades morts au combat
ainsi que tous les canadiens qui ont
donné leur vie au cours de différentes
guerres il y en a eu en tout cent seize
mille et tout de suite je vais rejoindre
notre collègue danielle thibeault qui
est déjà sur place à ottawa alors daniel
malgré ce temps assez froid toujours
beaucoup de monde pour cette cérémonie
du souvenir ont dit qu'à autour de 30
mille personnes qui se déplacent des
places et leur nombre augmente au fil
des ans
non ma lancée lundi c'est toujours
surprenant parce qu'effectivement il
fait très froid ici ce matin en malgré
cela les parterres de chaque côté du
monument commémoratif de guerre sont
remplis à des gens qui sont arrivés ici
depuis déjà une bonne heure une bonne
heure et demie des gens pour qui c'est
important d'être ici aujourd'hui c'est
la grande cérémonie évidemment au canada
tout ça se déroule aujourd'hui devant le
monument de guerre qui a été inauguré il
y à 80 ans marc georgeault 6 lors d'une
visite officielle en 1939 intéressant la
construction de ce monument là qui est
juste derrière nous commencé en 1926 les
statues de bronze qui ont pris plusieurs
années à être réalisés ont finalement
été acheminée en 1937 à ottawa et ce en
1938 que l'ensemble de l'oeuvre a été
complétée incluant le terrassement
inauguré donc en 1939 petit élément
d'information ça comporte ce monument la
503 tonnes de granit 32 tonnes de bronze
c'était à l'époque un cénotaphe depuis
depuis l'an 2000 alors qu'on ne rentre
trier les aime les restes du soldat
inconnu qui sont maintenant entrées sur
la tombe là bas juste derrière
c'est devenu le monument commémoratif de
guerre du canada et c'est ici chaque
année en plein centre-ville de la
capitale nationale où les gens viennent
se souvenir viennent souligner le
travail la mémoire de ceux qui sont
tombés au combat pour pour défendre ici
ces conflits dans lesquels ils sont des
canadiens ont par ont participé au fil
des ans
ouais on voyait donc des images du roi
george vi et c'est l'événement marquait
la première fois daniel qu'un monarque
régnant sur le canada visiter le pays en
fait c'était la première visite d'un
monarque régnant sur le canada visite de
six semaines il avait été organisée à ce
moment là qu'ils avaient permis qui
avait permis aux hommes au souverain de
de sillonner le pays et qui lui avait
permis à ce moment-là de venir inaugurer
le monument qui se trouve derrière nous
aujourd'hui
daniel vous serez avec nous tout au
cours de cette émission on se retrouve
tout à leur merci et je vous présente
maintenant mes deux invités sur ce
plateau alors le lieutenant-colonel
gilles paradis habituer nos émissions
que vous connaissez bien long que
retraité des forces canadiennes bon jour
en jour et on profite du passage de jean
baptiste papier à montréal pour l'avoir
avec nous sur ce plateau jean baptiste
patier qui journaliste historien
français est l'auteur de ce livre tout à
fait passionnant un reporter au coeur de
la libération c'est un livre donc sur le
travail de marcel wimet l'ancien
correspondant de guerre de radio-canada
donc pendant le débarquement de
normandie il était là et c'est donc
livre extraordinaire bonjour monsieur
pâtit bonjour c'est une toujours à tous
c'est vraiment un honneur d'être ici
oui aujourd'hui notre chance de vous
avoir avec nous pour nous parler de tout
ça donc ce jour du souvenir ça souligne
bien sûr l'entrée en vigueur de
l'armistice à 11 heures le 11 novembre
1918 l'armistice donc il ya mis fin à la
première guerre
mondiale c'est un moment très solennel
saunal elle solennelle bien sûr et c'est
un des conflits auxquels le canada a
participé alors donc peut-être commencer
par l'importance de cette cérémonie
l'objectif de ce genre de cérémonie vous
qui avaient été déployés dans plusieurs
pays l'allemagne chypre
vous avez fait plusieurs séjours en
afghanistan également mais ces paradis
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous
c'est un devoir de souvenir toujours se
souvenir du sacrifice de ceux qui ont
combattu pour préserver la paix assurer
notre sécurité nationale se souvenir
également que ces conflits même s'ils se
sont terminées il y en a d'autres qui se
poursuivent et qu'il faut continuer ce
devoir de se souvenir de ceux qui sont
actuellement déployées et qu'ils doivent
porter le flambeau de la paix souvenir
également des familles qui ont su porter
leurs proches qui étaient déployés à
l'étranger
alors il faut que la société canadienne
sache que le canada une responsabilité
dans la paix internationale par ses
diplomates
ces militaires également qui vont au
combat ou dans l'émission paix on se
souvenir doit toujours se perpétuer et
se transmettent aux futures générations
pour vous une pensée j'imagine certains
camarades sous est bon de camarades avec
qui j'ai juste servi et qui ne sont plus
là malheureusement aujourd'hui où sont
revenus avec des blessures physiques ou
psychologiques
et pour vous monsieur pâtit donc vous
qui êtes français et normand d'autres en
plus donc pour vous c'est important
c'est de voir de moi c'est très
important c'est essentiel vous avez dit
se rappeler les sacrifices nous
évidemment en normandie en france on est
très sensible à ce qu'ont fait les
canadiens durant cette seconde guerre
mondiale ils ont participé à notre
libération au retour de la démocratie
après la question c'est comment vivre ce
devoir de mémoire
eh bien nous par exemple c'est à l'école
avec l'enseignement de l'histoire en
participant à des commémorations mais
aussi au sein des familles puisque
migrants parents ont vécu l'occupation
allemande
mon grand mère a vécu les deux guerres
donc on en parle on grandit avec les
récits de nos ancêtres qui ont vécu nous
vu d'ailleurs les soldats cavadee une
grande tente effectivement a vu les
soldats canadiens arrivés à quand donc
il y à ce lien très fort avec cette
histoire et ce vécu c'était moins qu'ils
nous transmettent cette histoire mais
hélas le temps fait son oeuvre et les
témoins disparaissent ou comment
continuer à perpétuer ce devoir de
mémoire et bien voilà il ya des temps
très fort comme ce 75e anniversaire de
la libération de l'europe
un temps fort où on se retrouve pour
discuter échanger se souvenir et ses
grandes commémorations sont une occasion
très importante pour rassembler les
peuples rassembler les pays célébrait de
la libération et la démocratie
oui on voit des images l'angle de cette
cérémonie qui se prépare évidemment elle
va commencer solennellement à 11 heures
précises
on voit ici perry bellegarde de chefs
des premières nations
donc vous le disiez il ya de moins en
moins de témoins directs de cette
histoire il ne reste plus d'anciens
combattants de la première guerre
mondiale le dernier mot il est déjà
longtemps il est de moins en moins de la
seconde guerre mondiale on peut voir
d'ailleurs un tableau sur le jeu le
nombre d'anciens combattants qui demeure
au canada donc 33 mille deux cents ans
tous de la seconde guerre mondiale la
moyenne d'âge ses 94 ans il y en a de
moins en moins je pense qu'un à huit
mille de moins que l'an dernier donc ils
disparaissent peu à peu de la guerre des
corps et 6500 donc l'âge moyen 87 ans et
les autres vétérans ceux qui ont fait la
bosnie l'afghanistan donc 600 1200 les
réservistes également et la moyenne
d'âge est de 58 ans d'où l'importance de
ces cérémonies comme celle d'aujourd'hui
absolument oui devant on a souvent
l'image de vétérans comme quelqu'un de
d'âge qui a fait la deuxième guerre
mondiale mais il ya ce 600 milles
ce nom de 600000 vétérans qui ont
poursuivi la tradition de maintien de la
paix à travers une trentaine quarantaine
de missions de paix des nations unies et
qui ont participé au conflit comme vous
l'avez mentionné dans les balkans est
également en afghanistan et dans
d'autres théâtres d'opération alors ces
individus ces vétérans et vétérans
doivent avoir notre considération notre
respect oui on en voilà quelques-uns des
jeunes des moins jeunes évidemment c'est
difficile peut-être de sortir par ce
temps si froide et délits gens qui sont
très âgés aujourd'hui qui sont plus
fragiles peut-être mais on en voit
quelques-uns quand même qu'ils tiennent
à être là présent et aussi une foule
assez nombreuse daniel le disais tout à
l'heure alors on va vous présenter tout
de suite un reportage sur la mer à la
croix d'argent alors ça c'est une
tradition ici une vieille tradition
d'ailleurs qu'à 100 ans donc de cette
mère qui représente un peu toutes les
mères qui ont perdu un enfant au combat
et cette année nous allons voir madame
renée sont sereines samson d'or de
kingston son fils le capitaine matthew
johnson d'eau est mort en afghanistan le
4 juillet 2007 et donc c'est elle tout à
l'heure qui leur a déposé une couronne
donc au nom de toutes les mères qui ont
perdu un enfant
c'est un honneur qui porte avec lui
quand même des souvenirs assez
douloureux même si elle a réussi à
tourner la page
mathieu boyer va nous la présenter celui
à l'extrême droite c'est matthew goss
fait c'est pépé felly jane fonda n'a
jamais été militaire mais elle n'en n'a
pas moins consacré une bonne partie de
sa vie à l'armée femme d'un officier de
carrière l epita on tue quatre fils qui
ont grandi sur une vingtaine de bases
militaires
tous ont fait le choix de porter
l'uniforme dans la famille le sens du
devoir et omniprésent c'est ce qui a
poussé mathieu da à servir en
afghanistan
après une première mission rien ne
pouvait l'empêcher d'y retourner
pas même une déchirure du tendon
d'achille et l'ont vu en clinique sont
ibama tube désolé tu peux pas y aller ça
va prendre mais on en a récupéré et puis
on lui a offert l'option de rattacher ou
de faire de la réhabilitation graduelle
ils se rattachent à l'appui je vous
garantis que je vais je vais être prêt
et écrit en quatre mois
étaient prêts à partir le deuxième
séjour en afghanistan du capitaine
matthew da commandant de son peloton
aura été fatal
le 4 juillet 2007 sur une route à une
vingtaine de kilomètres de kandahar une
bombe téléguidée explose sous son
véhicule suivant les sept personnes à
bord
le temps atténue la douleur il les
parents de mathieu da sont aujourd'hui
capables d'évoquer avec bonheur leurs
plus beaux souvenirs sur ce toujours
m'étonne je pense matthew est mort le
jour du deuxième anniversaire de son
fils locus c'est aussi pour lui que ses
grands parents gardent le moral
j'ai vers petits-enfants moi je voulais
qu'ils viennent chez grand-maman un
grand d'adp qui s'amusent puisqu'ils
trouvent pas de maison en deuil
douze ans après la mort de matthew seren
sa mère qui poursuit une partie de sa
mission
on peut pas tout cinq soldats mais on
peut tous ces départs au sport cas des
causes sans amertume sans colère elle
refuse d'en vouloir au pays où son fils
est mort reine sans solde a plutôt
choisi de s'impliquer auprès de
l'organisme clinique in women for women
in afghanistan
sion ont fait un effort pour éduquer les
surtout les femmes il ya un effet qui de
sa vers l'est la population très
rapidement pour elle et toute sa famille
le dévouement quelque chose qui se vit
jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
ça fait cinq ans qu'on a commencé cette
tradition d'honorer les familles aussi
des soldats disparus et non pas
seulement les vétérans eux mêmes c'est
important quand même absolument oui
alors des familles qu'ils voient partir
des proches dans des zones d'opération
des jaunes de combat on ne sait pas
s'ils reviendront vivant ou blessés
alors ces familles vivent l'angoissé
durant les grands conflits mondiaux
beaumier guerre et deuxième guerre
mondiale c'était dans pendant des années
on devait subir cette angoisse et le
courrier n'arrivait pas régulièrement
parfois on avait les familles pouvaient
attendre des semaines et des semaines
avant d'attendre avant de recevoir une
lettre de leur fils alors pendant tout
ce temps est-ce qu'il est mort est-ce
qu'il est blessé pourquoi ce qui ne vous
écris pas alors les familles devaient
doivent être légalement honoré et
justement mais s'est passé vous avez eu
la chance en fait de tomber sur ces
lettres que marcel wimet le
correspondant de guerre donc de radio
canada au moment du débarquement de
normandie et de toute cette campagne de
libération de l'europe et donc vous avez
fait ce livre extraordinaire parce que
important parce que marcel wimet donne
une voix en fait un ou soldats canadiens
exactement marcel nuss un grand reporter
qui est présent partout à tous les
grands événements de libération de
l'europe league aux côtés des soldats il
est intégrée au corps armés ils
débarquent avec le régiment de la
chaudière dont qui va parler de ce que
vivent les soldats parler de ce que vaut
huit soldats au contact des civils car
quand on parle de libération ce sont des
des hommes des soldats qui apporte la
libération à des peuples est donc
marseille mais il est entre eux les
normands les normandes les européens
européenne qui rencontre ces soldats
libérateurs et la façon dont il écrit
ses rapports dans ces lettres ou dans
ses reportages c'est absolument
exceptionnel et c'est à un grand témoin
de ces échanges et oui il va parler de
ce que vivent les soldats et des
complications bien sûr sur le terrain
alors on attend l'arrivée du premier
ministre justin trudeau ensuite la mer
la croix d'argent ensuite la gouverneure
générale
julie payette mais on peut peut-être
écouter un extrait un court extrait d'un
reportage de marcelo mais vous allez
voir si c'est vraiment intéressant
marie-mai de radio-canada barreaux de
france
les premiers français que j'ai eu en
france ce sont ces dernières des
normands pour la plupart quelques
parisiens outil qui était venu à la
plage pour une vacance te sens-tu leurs
femmes et leurs filles ont lancé des
fleurs à nos troupes
comme elle défilait dans les rues
pourtant au cours de la nuit
il n'avait pas beaucoup dormi et pour
plusieurs le débarquement signifie à la
perte complète de leurs biens matériels
mais tout de même il se montrait heureux
il trouvait la force de sourire et de
crier les l'angleterre livre le canada
livre l'amérique
certaines nous sommes des répondants
livre intéressant quand même cette
rencontre donc des français des premiers
français qu'il voit et qui laissait
français qui découvrent donc des soldats
qui parlent français quand même alors ça
c'est vraiment ça revient dans tous les
témoignages des normands
jamais on n'aurait pu imaginer des
soldats intégrée au corps alliés
allaient parler la même langue que et ça
commence dès le 6 juin sur les plages de
normandie à juno beach dernière sur mer
marcel aymé débarque avec sa machine à
écrire sur l'épaule avec les soldats du
régiment de la chaudière et très vite
les normands les rencontres et donc je
vais voir des scènes de fraternisation
ils vont pouvoir échanger parler à la
lettre des modistes trudeau qui arrive
donc pour cette cérémonie accompagné de
son épouse sophie grégoire trudeau alors
on a perdu images quelques secondes mais
la voilà donc pour cette cérémonie qui
va commencer officiellement à 11h et
donc vous lisez c'est quand même
fascinant d'entendre ces anciens
reportage ces témoignages quand même
direct de marseille oui mais deux sets
de 7 de cette période qu'on l'a on se
souvient mais quand même il faut le
rappeler c'est la plus grande opération
commune
l'histoire de tous les temps c'est un
trésor d'informations sur reportage
parce que c'est le vécu des soldats
qu'ils accompagnent les soldats du
régiment de la chaudière dans leur
combat de maison en maison à l'ordre
chaque soir il envoie son reportage pour
indiquer pour démontrer pour informer
les gens qu'est ce que c'est que des
combats et des rencontres avec les
civils se trouvaient donc qui est
accueilli par les membres de la légion
canadienne
royale canadienne et aussi par le
ministre de la défense donc laurence
mark holick qui a été qui est en poste
depuis le mois de mars dernier sur ma
collègue a donc remplacé joe dit wilson
reebok dans sa série d'événements qui
entoure en évidemment la sphère snc
lavalin donc voilà john wilson et rob
avait démissionné c'est monsieur mark
holick a pris sa place
le général bien sûr 26la également
présents ils attendent maintenant la
gouverneure générale julie payette qui
devrait arriver au cours des prochaines
minutes donc des gens bien emmitouflés à
ottawa parce qu'on le disait ce n'est
pas chaud en ce moment il donc on va
poursuivre avec marseille n'est parce
que quand même c'est intéressant parce
qu'il écrit aussi des lettres à sa femme
vous les avez donc recueilli elles sont
dans ce livre et il se permet dans ces
lettres d'être un peu plus libre sur ce
que ce qu'il dit parce que pas oublier
que les correspondants à l'époque était
quand même soumis à la censure militaire
il faisait leur travail au sein de
l'armée et donc aux côtés des militaires
donc ces lettres là ils dénigrent
dénonce notamment les bombardements les
alliés marcel humez qui était très
sensible au vécu des civils et choqués
lorsqu'ils découvrent les villes en
ruines notamment la ville de caen il
parle d'ailleurs de l'esprit de quand ça
va resté avec lui durant tout la
libération de l'europe
et quand ils voient ce traumatisme des
civils ils s'interrogent dans ces
lettres ce qu'il ne peut pas faire dans
ce reportage dans ses lettres il dit à
quoi ont servi ces bombardements a
conservé ses ces centaines de morts et
ses villas 75% des truites est ce assez
c'est très très madame dame qui arrivent
nous a présenté un portrait tout à
l'heure et d'ailleurs il faut aussi
remercier les trois filles de marcel
wimet paul lise et rené qui ont accepté
que ces lettres soient rendus publics
parce que grâce à elle écrase bien sûr
aux écrits de leur père eh bien on peut
réfléchir à cette histoire et garder ce
devoir de mémoire
entretenir ce devoir de mémoire à
travers ses lettres sur les
bombardements notamment cédé question
que se sont posée les historiens
beaucoup plus tard en fait sur le poulpe
pourquoi de ces bombardements aussi
massifs qui ont touché la population
parce qu'il ya quand même des erreurs de
fait beaucoup d'erreurs et justement
dans un de ses reportages marcel mais
parle de précision mathématique dans ses
reportages précision mathématique or de
nombreuses bavures ont eu lieu et il se
rend compte qu'il ya des problèmes
quelque part pourquoi cette bombe tombe
là alors qu'elle devait tomber là
pourquoi autant de destruction et
effectivement ça il le révèle dans ses
lettres est absolument fascinant et
passionnant par l'époque willy boonen
n'avait pas la précision des bambins
moderne alors il fallait faire des
bombardements massifs et certains ce
jour et nuit avant le débarquement dans
le département après le débarquement
elle s'était pas de gaieté de coeur
quand même qu'on peut regarder les
villes françaises de pays alliés des
allemands s'y étaient retranchés
renforcée pour avoir accès aux plages et
ensuite poursuivre le français il
fallait des vélos jcc position défensive
allemand on a le choix était soit on
perd des milliers de soldats combattent
de maison à maison ou aux forces les
allemands par des bombardements a
peut-être sauvé et on souligne aussi
bien sur cette année le 75e anniversaire
de ce débarquement de normandie
si le cortège de madame julie payette
qui arrivent et qui devrait être
accompagnée de son fils laurier cassese
aujourd'hui un mot peut-être sur elle
ces lettres envoyées marché louis matte
ya des millions de lettres ont été
envoyées par les soldats canadiens à
leur famille ou à leur marraine de
guerre parfois on omet d'aider des
jeunes filles se tait volontaire est
marraine de guerre correspondre alors
une photo il faut garder c'est d'être
très important donc madame julie payette
qui arrivent et qui sera seul pour cette
cérémonie finale
[Musique]
elle est bien sûr la chef commandant en
chef des forces canadiennes et elles
portent l'uniforme cette année elles
changent chaque un nouveau cette année
c'est de l'uniforme de l'armée de terre
qu'elle porte de l'armée en fait de
l'armée de terre de l'armée
alors madame payet qui va être
accompagnée pour se rendre recevoir le
salut des cimes royal
[Musique]
c'est le troisième cérémonie du souvenir
pour julie payette à titre de
gouverneure générale elle a assisté à
plusieurs événements commémoratifs au
cours des derniers jours notamment en
normandie aux pays bas en pologne
également et elle avait un message
aujourd'hui pour les canadiens dans ce
message elle dix ont combattu pour
défendre nos idéaux de paix et de
liberté plusieurs ont été blessés dans
leur corps et dans leur âme
trop nombreux sont ceux qui ont fait le
sacrifice ultime on ne doit jamais tenir
la liberté pour acquise
il faut toujours défendre l'égalité et
la tolérance
nous avons le devoir de mémoire
aujourd'hui et à jamais l'importance du
devoir de mémoire
donc à ce genre de cérémonie fait gris
quand même à ottawa entend assez propice
pour ce genre de cérémonie du 11
novembre mais qui est très représentatif
de la température dans deux théâtres
d'opérations où il combattait des
soldats canadiens en jeu 10 h 30 et 15
heures
d'ailleurs marcel wimet décrivait un peu
ce temps très froid il est arrivé il a
dormi dans des tranchées avec les
soldats et c'était des conditions
extrêmement difficiles extrêmement
difficile bien sûr avec la bataille de
l'escaut à l'automne aider le
débarquement et c'est important de
souligner ce point là où madame galipeau
il tord dans une tranchée le 6 juin au
soir
on parle souvent des correspondants de
guerre comme robert capa ou ernest
hemingway
mais l'un comme l'autre n'étaient pas
sur le sol normand le 6 juin au soir et
marcel aymé
là dormi là au milieu de la population
dans une tranchée dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles de queen décrits
régulièrement
et bien cette vie d'itinérance et où il
faut le rappeler aussi la mort rôde
partout et ils étaient moins de cela et
il le raconte dans ses lettres dans ce
rapport dont marcel wimet était le seul
correspondant francophone d'abord avoir
assisté à ce débarquement et ensuite à
toute la campagne parce qu'il va pas il
part de l'italie en 1943 et il finit à
berlin en 1945 avec la chute d'hitler
exactement c'est le seul récit
francophone du jour j est à l'heure
actuelle quand on travaille sur
l'histoire des correspondants de guerre
qui est en fait une dimension de la
seconde guerre mondiale assez assez
méconnu il y à un chercheur risque
renata qui s'appelle aimé juvisy mana
qui travaillent dessus également mais
quand on réfléchit quand on regarde cela
on ne voit pas de parcours similaire à
marcel vie mais parce que marcel wimet
ils étaient présents partout italie
paris-normandie pays-bas berlin il a
même couvert l'issue de la seconde
guerre mondiale et le procès du maréchal
pétain en france pour radio-canada donc
oui il était présent partout ce qui en
fait un grand témoin de l'issue de ce
conflit
madame payet qui s'entretenait il ya
quelques instants avec la mer à la croix
d'argent dans madame da et vous voyez
cette foule quand même
massés autour du momment du monument
commémoratif de guerre
beaucoup de gens qui viennent et qui
veulent rendre hommage à tous ces
anciens combattants dont il ya un
intérêt un nouvel intérêt peut-être un
peu oui de pour lui la chose militaire
je dirais depuis une trentaine d'années
on a vu progressivement l'intérêt de la
population envers ce jour du souvenir se
rappeler que ce sont pas des étrangers
six soldats ce sont nos proches sont nos
fils nos frères et puis on a un lien
avec e.on et puis au fond avec les
reportages également deux sont
effectuées par les chaînes de télévision
on a vu les soldats en opération alors
le lien s'est tissé entre les militaires
les soldats et la population en général
et on sent maintenant de plus en plus
que oui ce sont nos gars se sont enfuis
ou 6 également et puis ils font un
travail extraordinaire pour préserver
nos valeurs
en fait c'est une grande différence avec
est peut-être 30 ans parce que vous le
disiez ça ça a beaucoup évolué mais il
ya trente ans il ya des gens qui osaient
pas porter leurs uniformes pour aller
dans les villes ce qui est quand même
extraordinaire qu'aujourd'hui on pense
que c'est aberrant mais oui il ya une
époque qui à 30 40 ans alors le
gouvernement interdisait aux militaires
de se présenter dans les commerces au
retour de leur entraînement dirigé vers
la résidence alors s'était très mal vu
seulement alors on se présentait dans
seulement lors des cérémonies
officielles comme ça dure 11 novembre
autrement on sait quand au niveau dans
vos bases
et choyé soyez dans l'eau alors vous les
voyez tout le monde va se préparer à
s'installer pour la cérémonie qui va
débuter dans quelques instants c'est un
moment toujours solennel qui vient
chercher des émotions qu'on refoule
souvent parce que c'est très touchant de
voir ces vétérans un peu fragile et
vulnérable mais très fier très bien avec
leur médaille alors il y aura les deux
minutes de silence la sonnerie aux morts
l'acte du souvenir
on va regarder tout ça ensemble et se
retrouvaient pour poursuivre notre
mission ensuite
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
mais
dix ans
à rome
oui
c'est
m
oui
[Musique]
comment
avant
[Musique]
oh
oui
[Musique]
les chefs journal of hell with the red
cross in china with m l'audi r15 n était
qu un gars inamori ils ne vivront pas
quand nous qui leur avons survécu et le
connaîtrons jamais le courage ni le
poids des années
quand viendra l'heure du crépuscule et
ce alors hors du de souviendrons d'eux
barack obama pirate a questionné thomas
p au p
ochoa lac titicaca est notre obama
national à kanata nice à cannes national
mannschaft et noya
[Musique]
wigg adultes ou des formes cros canada
tout à fait hors taxes fotos ou afghanes
dans toutes les régions du canada nous
nous rassemblons aujourd'hui rendre
hommage à ceux et celles qui ont donné
leur vie pour la liberté et la paix nos
humbles et fort de ce matin les zones
avec les nobles efforts de ceux et
celles que nous nommons aujourd'hui à
voix haute ou dans le silence de nos
coeurs ils nous respectent et une main
d'oeuvre dans le respect des croyances
individuelles et de la conscience de
chacun chacune
je vous invite à prendre un moment de
recueillement des croyances
individuelles et de la conscience de
chacun et chacune
je vous invite à prendre ce moment de
recueillement à suivre les membres
d'oser rose ou afghanes bifaces please
gens et demi bel esprit vous joindre à
moi en répétant nous nous souviendrons
de héros qui nous ont précédés veillez
s'il vous plaît vous joindre à moi en
répondant nous nous souviendrons de
chaque fois que je prononcerai ses mots
et de présence aux fauves et 30 en
présence de nos anciens combattants
l'incarnation vivante du courage du
service nous désirons prendre un moment
pour nous souvenir de ces hommes et de
ces femmes qui ont servi notre pays à 20
afin que nous puissions vivre en liberté
et en paix
nous nous souviendrons d'eux nous nous
souvenons également du 75e anniversaire
de la campagne d'italie
nous rendons grâce pour la détermination
de ces militaires pour la force et la
volonté nécessaires pour faire face aux
épreuves
le thème campagne alors que nous nous
souvenons du nombre de ceux et celles
qui ont combattu et qui sont morts ceux
et celles qui ont perdu un être cher se
souviennent de nom d'un visage
nous nous souviendrons d'eux
[Musique]
nous souvenons des canadiens et
canadiennes dont le lieu de naissance
situe bien au delà des côtes du canada
mais qui se sont battus qui sont morts
pour la liberté
nous nous souviendrons d'eux avait c'est
avec une profonde gratitude que nous
nous souvenons de nos anciens
combattants et de nos militaires
toujours en service qui souffrent de
blessures physiques ou psychologiques
puissions-nous également faire preuve
d'une grande compassion envers ceux et
celles qui ont mis fin au combat de leur
vie parce que la souffrance offering la
souffrance était trop vive hausse de
désespoir surpoids fort les empêcher de
voir une issue souviendront du puissions
nous nourrir l'espérance que la vie est
plus forte que la mort we pray for the
leader of the world
nous prions pour les dirigeants de ce
monde et pour ceux de notre pays pour
notre souveraine elizabeth ii la
gouverneure générale et des blancs ville
de john woo le premier ministre
tu évoques ainsi que le chef
d'état-major de la défense rassemblés
dans un esprit de réconciliation afin de
manifester les uns aux autres notre
détermination à faire tomber les
barrières de la division ouicher de la
cherchons à établir le dialogue des uns
avec les autres
quand tous les domaines social politique
et religieux
d'où une show afin de parvenir à une
paix durable
qu'il en soit ainsi et puissions nous
tous nous efforcer de poursuivre nos
efforts pour construire un monde
meilleur
amen
[Musique]
ladies and gentlemen mesdames et
messieurs le cortège royal déposera
maintenant les couronnes
[Musique]
c'est
et
mais comme vous voyez la gouverneure
générale qui vient de déposer une
couronne au nom de tous les canadiens
tous les dignitaires vont faire ensuite
le premier ministre la mer à la croix
d'argent ainsi que le corps diplomatique
est ce que vous entendez c'est la
chorale des jeunes d'ottawa qui chantent
au champ d'honneur in flanders fields
donc c'est un c'est un chant qui a été
adopté suite aux poèmes du lieutenant
colonel john mccrae qui parle donc de
ces fameux coquelicot qui poussait sur
les champs de bataille d'europe pendant
la première guerre mondiale
le coquelicot donc il devenu symbole du
souvenir dans le cadre des financements
de campagnes de financement de la légion
royale canadienne d'ailleurs qui
recueillent autour de 16 millions de
dollars encore aujourd'hui avec ces
petits coquelicot comporte et que les
gens iront déposer
dans quelques minutes sur la tombe du
soldat inconnu
et pour se souvenir évidemment de cette
journée de cette cérémonie qui commémore
donc là réussissent bien sûr la fin de
la première guerre mondiale mais
également tous les autres confie toutes
les autres guerres qu'elle le canada ont
participé
là c'est le premier ministre justin
trudeau qui déposent une couronne à son
tour on va retrouver maintenant daniel
thibault qui assistait donc à cette
cérémonie comme nous une cérémonie
empreinte d'émotion très solennelle bien
sûr et vous vous avez participé à vous
avez assisté un autre travail de mémoire
bagnell parce que vous avez été un peu
plus tôt cette semaine au cimetière
national de beach où sont enterrés de
nombreux militaires et vous avez
retrouvé le jeune élève
voilà céline en fait parce que la
cérémonie d'aujourd'hui c'est le point
culminant de la semaine du souvenir
il ya des activités d'un bout à l'autre
du pays est vraiment un paquet
d'activités des expositions des super
des visionnements de documentaires des
cérémonies et vous le disiez au
cimetière beechwood qui le cimetière
militaire national du canada la semaine
dernière et un groupe d'écoliers qui se
sont donné rendez vous pour aller pour
aller commémoré pour aller
souligner la mémoire des militaires qui
sont enterrés là bas alors ils ont ils
se sont munis de petits coquelicot qui
sont allés déposer sur chacune des
tombes en lisant à voix haute le nom de
la personne qui était inscrite sur la
pierre tombale signe de respect pour se
souvenir je me suis entretenu avec un
certain nombre de saisir de ses équipes
de ses écoliers voici ce que ça donne tu
rester privilégiées en même temps 13
parce qu'on peut voir tous et tous ces
personnes mort et c'est un petit et
c'est vraiment triste de voir tout les
personnes mais c'est aussi un privilège
parce que ben on regarde aux personnes
qui ont gardé notre notre pays en
sécurité
c'est un peintre est mais c'est aussi
content qu'ils ont fait quelque chose
l'armee là pour si ça arrive encore mais
je vraiment fera que ça arrive encore
les frais poignant c'était très touchant
de les voir ces jeunes prendre le temps
sur chacune des pierres à chacune des
pierres tombales pour regarder
attentivement certain qu'ils trouvaient
des liens de parenté avec certains des
individus qui étaient là bas qui ont su
souvenait de leur grand-père d'un an 22
d'une tante qui a servi c'est un peu
touche à l'image de ce que vous allez
voir vous le mentionnez tout à l'heure
ce que vous allez voir à la fin de la
cérémonie six quelque chose quelqu'un
qui a commencé il ya déjà quelques
années
spontanément les gens et là il ya
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de monde
autour du monument commémoratif de
guerre du canada
après le dernier défilé quand les gens
vont quitter le public claqué massés le
long de la place ici va se diriger vers
la tombe du soldat inconnu sur laquelle
ils vont déposer leurs coquelicot c'est
le dernier moment c'est le dernier
hommage qui est rendu dans le cadre de
cette cérémonie
oui un moment très fort de cette
cérémonie merci daniel et je voudrais
maintenant avec nos invités sur le
plateau le lieutenant-colonel à la
retraite gilles paradis et le
journaliste et historien jean baptiste
le papier donc une façon d'encourager
quand même les jeunes a justement à ce
devoir de mémoire
oui effectivement de plus en plus on
voit les écoles qui amènent les jeunes
mordus le jour du souvenir pour
participer à ces cérémonies relais alors
on les emmène of leon leur fait
comprendre la signification de ce tir et
money et les instituteurs des les
enseignants les prépare avant cette
cérémonie et leur explique pourquoi
est-ce que ses soldats ont dû aller à
l'extérieur du pays pour défendre le
canada et ça se fait bien sûr
hier ça se fait en france notamment et
ça c'est bien sûr sont en terre normande
là où les soldats canadiens ont débarqué
au cimetière par exemple de béni sur mer
à quelques kilomètres de la côte des
jeunes lycéens d
des petites bougies sur les tombes
canadienne les autres tombent aussi des
alliés sont fleuries donc oui en
normandie des jeunes sont impliqués dans
ce devoir de mémoire qui passe par des
actions notamment dans les soutiens mais
aussi par exemple aux portes de la mer
il ya un groupe de jeunes qui a lu tous
les noms des soldats canadiens durant
toute une nuit
quelques temps avant le le 6 juin face à
la mer dans ce lieu de mémoire
parce qu'il faut pas oublier qu'il ya
des vieux de mémoire de normandie c'est
un lieu de mémoire et quand ces jeunes
sont face à laver vos cours de nombreux
lieux et quand on est confronté à
l'esprit du lieu mais généralement les
colorations sont très forts ce qui est
ce qu'on n'a pas chez nous ce paradis
parce que le canada n'a pas été impliqué
directement les canadiens n'ont pas vécu
de guerre sur le territoire non n'a pas
connu de ceux de telles guerres de
telles choses si affreuse que
l'occupation et une destruction de
nouveau bien la perte de nous de nos
enfants de nos parents lors des
bombardements
alors c'est ce devoir de mémoire entre
quand même le perpétue à travers des
liens étroits entre le canada et les
pays avec lesquels on a combattu
il ya d'ailleurs en france maintenant le
centre juno sur la plage près de la
plage où débarquent des canadiens et si
ceux qui nous écoutent vont faire un
tour en france allait au centre juno et
vous le comprendrez ce lien étroit
maintenant que c'est établi ils se
renforcent aussi entre le canada et la
france l'est qui reçoit des millions de
visiteurs
ah oui exactement c'est cette partie des
2e peut-être plus grands musées des
commémorations du débarquement et du
travail scientifique et historique vous
avez même marial de camp qui est très
connu et le sans toit d'une bille sur
les plages est vraiment un lieu très
important qui combine à la fois une
présence physique
là où les soldats canadiens ont débarqué
et à la fois un lieu où on réfléchit
pédagogique aussi de transmission de
l'histoire et la mémoire non c'est
vraiment un lieu très important
le centre du lot beach un petit mot
quand même parce que c'est sûr que
aujourd'hui on les honore on
on commémore tous ces événements on se
souvient d'eux mais demain demain de
quoi sera-t-il fait pour ces anciens
combattants parce qu'encore beaucoup de
frustration mais ce paradis de par
rapport à ce que ce qu'ils reçoivent les
fonds de retraite la façon dont ils sont
traités
on sent beaucoup de méfiance encore chez
les anciens combattants face à un
gouvernement qui peut-être ne leur a pas
donné tout ce qu'ils espèrent il ya eu
des périodes chambre effectivement au
cours des récentes de leçons des années
il ya eu des coupures importantes au
ministère des anciens combattants et des
centres de soutien aux vétérans qui ont
été abolies durant la période du
gouvernement harper qui ont été
rétablies avec le gouvernement trudeau
mais il ya encore cette culture
bureaucratique qui répètent persiste un
peu trop longtemps au ministère des
anciens combattants et les anciens
combattants souvent démunis blessés avec
des problèmes psychologiques avait des
difficultés à faire reconnaître leurs
blessures ou leur trauma psychologique
et devait passer à travers un véritable
champ de mines pour faire ce faire
diagne a diagnostiqué avoir un suivi
consistant et également avoir un soutien
pour leur réintégration la vie civile et
un soutien ensuite permanent de speak et
de spécialistes en psychologie et ça
manque toujours un ya encore des
problèmes aujourd'hui est là on l'attend
peut-être de voir qui va être nommé
signal important est ce que ce sera un
minus qui offre de premier plan un peu
trop souvent c'était un ministère de
secondaire 2 troisièmement nous on
envoyait une personne qui avait été
début d éminents quelqu'un qui y voyait
son ministère comme un premier pas vers
un mystère plus importants alors il faut
quelqu'un qui soit stable dans ce
ministère
bien appuyé par sa bureaucratie et qui
est là pour servir les vétérans parce
que ça reste difficile hein on dit qu'il
ya trois mille anciens combattants qui
auraient fait appel à des refuges qui se
retrouve donc à l'art
lui carrément et je sais pas en france
comment sont traités les anciens
combattants mais on y est pas venu un
peu partout aux états-unis aussi c'est
très difficile de réintégrer la vie
civile
c'est très difficile parce qu'il ya
comme un sentiment de solitude
tu as vu quand vous retrouvez vos
proches ils n'ont pas vécu ce que vous
avez vécu
marcel humez ce correspondant de terre
de radio canada avec tout cela quand il
est rentré au canada comme tous les
soldats avec qu'il était sur les
théâtres d'affrontements
c'est cette première solitude qui est
très difficile après l'accompagnement
existe en france pour les retours
contemporain je dirais des conflits
actuels
mais après la seconde guerre mondiale ça
a été difficile notamment pour les
français du jour j -c français du
débarquement est la france a mis
beaucoup de temps à les reconnaître
moi je me rappelle une cérémonie très
émouvante on voit ces hommes du commando
kieffer les seuls français fantassins du
jour j qui ont débarqué en secteur
britannique
il a fallu attendre 2014 pour voir ses
hommes décorait recevoir des légions
d'honneur
comment oublier d'être monté les
spectateurs que la france est occupée à
cette époque ya donc bien sûr la france
est tombée existerait qui est très
différent exactement c'était donc très
très compliqué d'ailleurs pour avoir des
français dans les effectifs du
débarquement
il a eu seulement 177 français fantasmes
et bien le comprendre il fallait quitter
la france traversait la manche ou passer
par l'espagne depuis l'occupation change
complètement la donne pour rejoindre les
lakers en mai elle explique aussi qu'il
ya pas de journalistes français en fait
un qui à 6000 voilà ce que le média
officiel français il est à paris est
paris est occupée et radio paris puisque
on parlerait de cada radio paris où
disait radio paris ment radio paris est
tellement nous fallait écouter en
catimini la radio de londres avec les
français parlent aux français etc
mais en terme de deux récits
radiophonique du 6 juin en langue
française c'est marcelo mais il y avait
des journalistes francophones de presse
écrite mais en récit radiophonique
francophone fait marcel oui mais alors
d'où l'importance de notre ancien
correspondant là dans quelques instants
ça va être la bénédiction
que qu'on va écouter ensemble et on se
retrouve tout de suite après
or
non
tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est donc dans la sérénité loi on
attend la bénédiction et ensuite ce sera
le défilé des anciens combattants de
tous ceux qui sont présents là pour
cette cérémonie et tous les dignitaires
vont se dépasser dans pour aller
regarder observer assister à ce défilé
dans quelques instants elle devrait
commencer
donc on parlait de l'importance en fait
d'un correspondant comme marcel humez
dans ce genre de couverture parce que
c'était le seul journaliste francophone
dont va avoir assisté à tout ça et on va
parler aussi de toutes ces batailles
parce qu'il a couverts évidemment une
grande partie de cette campagne du
nord-ouest très importante pour le
canada il sourit les troupes canadiennes
après le débarquement du combattre
férocement contre une défense allemande
kaunas qui avait alors dit l'air de
tenir à tout coup et puis les batailles
de km2 fallait j'ai ensuite la
libération des ports du nord de la
france dont dieu qui était
particulièrement important pour le
canadien pour venger en quelque chose là
le raid de 1942 ou s'il y avait été
sanglant pour les canadiens et la
poursuite ensuite vers la belgique la
libération des approches port d'anvers
la campagne de hollande
alors tous à amener des pertes de
plusieurs milliers de soldats canadiens
dans des conditions tellement
épouvantable
ouais et donc on a sonné ce témoignage
de marcel wimet qui donne une voix à ces
soldats et qui nous expliquent au jour
le jour un peu comment tout ça se passe
et ce qui est extrêmement précieux c'est
très précieux parce que c'est inédit
effectivement le front se déplacer
notamment de la bataille de l'escaut au
niveau des pays bas le front se
déplaçait très vite et entre l'arrière
du flon marcel mullet aller travailler
et ensuite ses incursions sur le fond
pour raconter ce qui se passe et avait
des centaines de kilomètres dans le
froid dans la pluie est lui rentré après
et écrire ce reportage ans attend et
c'est donc les soldats canadiens ont
vécu vraiment une campagne très
difficile pour cette bataille de les
secours qui était l'âge peut être un peu
trop oublié par rapport au débarquement
[Musique]
était ce difficile
elle varie de cet espace sacré pour nous
souvenir
nous sommes tous ici pour nous souvenir
pour exprimer notre gratitude
nous voulons être reconnaissant envers
l'engagement de ceux qui se sont
sacrifiés tant de canadiens aimé se sont
sacrifiés et accepte de sacrifier sur
terre en mer dans l'air reconnaissons et
survivants les endeuillés et combattants
nous reconnaissons les peuples
autochtones les francophones et les
anglophones ainsi que les leaders des
différentes communautés culturelles le
remercions aujourd'hui de défendre les
libertés
nous remercions les jeunes anciens
combattants et les anciens combattants
plus âgés ils se sont engagés pour
combattre le mal c'est dans l'objectif
de défendre les droits de tout le monde
nous apprécions leur participation nous
apprécions leur bravoure
nous apprécions leur dignité nous
apprécions leur dévouement
nous apprécions leur amour du canada
[Musique]
nous apprécions qu'ils se soient engagés
envers le maintien de la paix nous
apprécions qu'ils aient risquer leur
avenir pour nous et nous savons que même
s'ils reviennent au canada complet et
sans blessures physiques ils ont subi
des blessures psychologiques
nous apprécions le dévouement de chacun
et du fait qu'il nous rappelle ce que ça
veut dire être canadiens ceux qui ont
été blessés soient guéris dans leur tête
dans leur âme et dans leur corps que le
monde puisse vivre sans terreur dans le
calme comment continuer à remercier nos
anciens combattants en les accueillant
on les êtres aignan en leur exprimant
notre appréciation partout tout le temps
en apprenant à nos enfants à quel point
nous leur devons notre vie soyons à la
hauteur de leur sacrifice au canada
alors que nous célébrons le 75e
anniversaire du débarquement
nous pensons à ceux d aujourd j qu'est
ce que ça veut dire
ce n'est pas spécifique mais je pense
qu'on peut faire de cette année une
année cruciale une année forte
comment est ce qu'on fait et bien fait
en sorte d'honorer ce que nos anciens
combattants ont voulu protéger devons
protéger notre destinée en tant que pays
aujourd'hui nous devons utiliser
diligence discipline pour atteindre le
rêve canadien
que dieu bénisse nos anciens combattants
que dieu bénisse
les troupes que dieu bénisse tous le
monde
que dieu bénisse le canada à madame et
monsieur que dieu protège la reine
[Musique]
c'est
et
on
[Musique]
ladies and gentlemen de mars il commence
alors voilà pour la partie plus
solennelle de la cérémonie les dignité
avant maintenant se classer pour le
défilé des anciens combattants dont
c'est eux qui vont reprendre instruit
leur place dans ce dans cette cérémonie
et qui vont défiler et montrer leurs
couleurs parce que chaque régime enfin
chacun va porter chaque service armée de
terre aviation marine la réserve aussi
et puis les vétérans on pourrait
peut-être apercevoir en plus des
vétérans b où traditionnellement on
pourrait peut-être apercevoir des
vétérans qui maintenant se sont formés
dans des groupes de soutien
il porte une veste arborant leurs
couleurs régimentaire et leur écusson
leur médaille alors si jamais des gens
envoient dans les rues n'hésitez pas à
les leur part des îles sont en mes
chances ils sont rentrés heureux de vous
les motards se sont bien des anciens
combattants seront très heureux de vous
raconter la signification de la de leur
carrière de chacun ainsi qu'une porte
voix la gouverneure générale
payet qui sert des mains et qui parle à
certains de ses anciens combattants sur
place et donc on parlait de marcel wimet
et de son rôle dans cette danse est le
rôle des correspondants en fait parce
que c'est un peu ce qu'il incarne lui et
on parlait des grandes batailles
auxquelles ont participé les canadiens
il ya eu aussi cette bataille
deux camps donc en juillet 44 qui a
permis aux britanniques de percer le
front allemand donc très importante et
je voulais juste qu'on écoute un petit
extrait quand il est arrivé et qu'il
assiste donc après après la libération
de caen on va écouter un petit extrait
de marcel vachon de la part du même
jeune homme j'ai lu une infection da
évitables et d'émotion face mais le long
des campagnes où ils ne paient pas
d'odeur mais pleurez de verser des
larmes ramadan parce que c'était la
libération soudaine
[Musique]
on est quand même en 1944 donc
évidemment le son la technique il avait
une d'énormes problèmes techniques
pendant cette guerre pour transmettre
ses reportages mais c'est quand même
extrêmement émouvant d'entendre ça et
c'est un des documents que vous avez
recueillis oui beaucoup d'émotions en
plus cela je pense à tous les normands 2
les normands les gens de ma famille qui
a vécu cette aberration quand et les
canadiens ont eu un rôle vraiment
essentiel parce que la bataille de car
piqué qui est le prélude de la bataille
de camphin de l'issue de la bataille de
caen où les canadiens ont dû affronter
des amants des jeunes ainsi clairière
fanatisés comme le dit dans sa lettre
dans ses reportages d'ailleurs marcel
oui mais est ce qu'on fait les canadiens
à carpiquet pour ensuite permettre la
percée a été vraiment déterminante cette
action a été déterminante
non content de rentrer dans quand ils
découvrent ces civils il découvre cette
ville en partie en ruine il va assister
à cette cérémonie donc c'est beaucoup
d'émotion parce que le siège de caen a
duré un mois pour le rappeler c'est
seulement un mois après le débarquement
contenus divers à led et quand les
alliés y arrive les canadiennes un rôle
essentiel et donc les les cannes et des
canettes quand ils voient ces canadiens
arrivés enfin se libérer enfin on peut
retrouver la liberté la liberté aussi de
chanter la marseillaise au journal oui
plusieurs fêtes
j'imagine bien que tout ce qui était lié
à la république française et à regarder
de très près par les nazis et donc ce
chantre de la révolution française ce
champ de la liberté était interdite est
parfois utilisée par la résistance pour
fredonner lors de commémorations et puis
un petit peu embêté l'occupant si vous
voulez mais là enfin la marseillaise et
chanter librement et marcel mais là avec
son appareil enregistreur et là ce que
nous avons entendu c'est vraiment très
émouvant et très important le retour de
la république et leur retour de la
liberté grâce au canadien
oui la ville de caen était l'objectif
pour le sujet
la ville devait être capturés dumont
espère capturer la ville de caen et ça a
été beaucoup plus difficile que ça me
dit notre collègue un mois de combats
acharnés aux portes de la ville alors
les civils dans la ville s'attendait
d'un jour à l'autre a été libéré mais
s'attarde s attarder et les
bombardements tué malheureusement
décibulles autour d'eux pendant qu'on
voit des premières images donc de se
dessiner c'est quelque chose quand même
qu'il soit là encore aujourd'hui pour
marcher comme ça c'est très très fort et
je pense bien sûr aussi à ce qui se
passe en normandie quand les canadiens
viennent parce que quand les vétérans
canadiens viennent en normandie ils sont
acclamés et beaucoup de jeunes vont les
voir recueillir leurs témoignages
c'est très important il ya un lien fort
entre la normandie la france et le
canada par cette histoire très
importante et ses hommes qui doivent
importer la lire rappelons-nous aussi
que la majorité des des français qui
sont mis en oeuvre ces deux originaires
de la normandie la grossesse ou bien ce
sont des meilleurs et il le mentionne
inversément dans ses reportages comme
dans ces lettres martha ne me raconte
bien que pour beaucoup de soldats
canadiens et un retour un peu aux
sources d'une certaine façon est donc
c'est très symbolique aussi de libérer
convaincant disais voilà la terre de nos
ancêtres
c'est ce qu'il dit dans ce reportage est
dans ses lèvres et parfois nos anciens
combattants manque peut-être de
reconnaissance où on ne leur en donne
pas assez mais marcel wimet dit aussi
que pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
les soldats canadiens n'avaient pas
peut-être cette la reconnaissance qu'il
méritait parce que c'était au fond les
britanniques et les américains qui
prenait toute la place où qu'ils se
donnaient tout le crédit ça aussi c'est
intéressant et je dis lancé lettre où il
explique très bien et c'est vrai que
c'est montgomery britannique qui dirige
les forces terrestres le chef suprême et
américains c'est eisenhower donc
effectivement oui mais la sensation est
parfois à juste titre l avoir cette
sensation et cette impression que les
américains les britanniques et bien on
la part la plus belle comme il dit après
les effectifs étaient plus importants
côté britannique et américain mais ce
n'est pas pour cela que les canadiens
n'ont pas eu un rôle important au
contraire les canadiens comptent eu un
rôle clé et marcel humez le dit
et le répète et puis il faut dire aussi
les américains étaient et sont très
forts en termes de propagande donc il ya
aussi cette notion de communication très
maîtrisée par les américains ouais donc
peut-être que les canadiens ont été trop
les troupes canadiennes courbet tech ou
un haut commandement britannique
mais au fur et à mesure de la
progression des forces canadiennes des
troupes canadiennes à l'intérieur de la
france vers la belgique alors l'armée
canadienne se reconstituait comme une
information de plus en plus puissantes
à la fin de la guerre les troupes qui
avaient combattu en italie sont venus
renforcer le front canadien dans le nord
de l'europe et alors on a bien une
première armée canadienne qui était de
l'ordre d'un quart de million de soldats
alors jamais on n'avait on avait vu
auparavant
quelles forces canadiennes ont nolan on
ne reverra sans doute jamais plus une
force armée canadienne d'une telle
importance sur un théâtre d'opérations
alors je vais à les joindre maintenant
ma collègue cassandra nadeau depuis le
monument de gerd halifax où il ya des
cérémonies qui ont aussi été célébré un
peu plus tôt à cause du décalage il faut
dire que c'est une ville aux racines
militaire bien ancrée alors qu'elle s'en
rendra les centaines de personnes
étaient là devant l'hôtel de ville ce
matin
oui voilà il ya une cérémonie solennelle
qui s'est déroulée aux alentours de 11h
heure de l'atlantique en présence de
plusieurs dignitaires dont le lieutenant
gouverneur de la nouvelle écosse joseph
arthur leblanc et comme à chaque année
cette cérémonie se déroule ici à la
place grégoire qui a été érigée juste
devant l'hôtel de ville en hommage aux
personnes qui ont perdu la vie en temps
de guerre et il ya plusieurs autres
cérémonies qui se sont déroulées un peu
partout à halifax en nouvelle écosse et
qui continue de se dérouler d'ailleurs
il ya des activités commémoratives au
site historique de la citadelle
d'halifax toute la journée
un lieu qui est aussi très important
pour l'histoire de l'armée canadienne
il faut dire que halifax et même la
nouvelle écosse au complet ont une forte
tradition militaire halifax possède la
plus grande base navale au canada et il
ya plusieurs autres bases militaires un
peu partout à travers
la nouvelle écosse alors c'est important
pour les gens de se commémorer de
commémorer est aussi de rendre hommage
aux vétérans et aux personnes qui sont
présentement un membre des forces armées
je vous propose d'écouter quelques
témoignages recueillis ce matin depuis
mon arrivée ici c'est qu'on na li est
très très près on a daily c'est très
fort avec la population les gens sont
très fiers de toutes les unités qui sont
dans leurs communautés nous avons à des
unités de réserve look sont dispersés à
travers l'atlantique et chaque année on
voit vraiment un support incroyable pour
les troupes de l'atlantique
lorsqu'on a en son rôle on est prêt à
tout c'est un petit peu comme si on
signe un chèque en blanc et faut
reconnaître pour apprécier sur puis on
reconnaît tous ces gens là aujourd'hui
alors les cérémonies vont continuer un
peu partout en atlantique aujourd'hui et
ce soir allez faire que ça va se
terminer avec une messe commémorative
dans une des églises catholiques de la
ville
oui alors ça se poursuit merci cassandra
un peu partout en nouvelle écosse et on
va rejoindre justement à québec
jean pierre alexandre bolduc qui a
également assisté aux célébrations du 11
novembre qui se sont déroulés à la croix
du sacrifice bien sûr en présence du
premier ministre françois legault
oui céline saviez tout juste de se
terminer je voudrais qu'il y avait un
peu plus de 600 personnes qui étaient
ici il y avait bien évidemment la parade
militaire traditionnel on s'est
entretenu céline avec des gens dans la
foule justement il y avait bien
évidemment des militaires en service qui
nous ont parlé du sacrifice aussi
familial d'être dans l'art mais
également des vétérans qui nous ont
expliqué qu'ils avaient passé
vous savez plusieurs mois en afghanistan
qu'ils avaient perdu des amis des
compatriotes alors ce jour du souvenir
si à l'époque pour certains c'était
plutôt une célébration des grandes
guerres la première et de la deuxième
guerre mondiale d'un pour bien des gens
qui étaient ici en tout cas c'est ce que
j'ai senti ça prend une signification
une tournure tout autre jeu repose les
entendre
[Musique]
ça nous permet de nous remémorer d'où on
vient qu'est ce qu'on a fait et s'il ya
un moment pour est contraint de mandat
fait penser à tous ceux qui ont sacrifié
je tiens ces crimes pour la vie par une
partie des visas mais pour le pays du
canada puis des fois on pense ici aux
militants sa femme simulant machine même
temps que lui
et des jeunes garçons naissaient oui le
premier ministre s'est dit très ému
justement par cette cérémonie en hommage
à tous ceux qui ont combattu pour leur
patrie oui c'est parce qu'il faut savoir
que le monument et si la croix du
sacrifice est vraiment à deux pas là de
l'assemblée nationale alors le premier
ministre françois legault qui était
présent avec sa vice première ministre
geneviève guilbault horizons ils ont
déposé également une gerbe de fleurs ici
ils ont ensuite marché devant les
militaires on va entendre françois
legault qui vient tout juste de nous
donner sa réaction devant la mémoire des
gens courageux qui ont défendu notre
liberté
c'est touchant de voir les données sont
pas quatre ans ça m'allait demain qui
par son mari alors céline il yad'autres
d'autres célébrations d'autres
cérémonies à la base militaire de
valcartier pas bien loin d'ici et puis
pour l'instant bien des gens qui
viennent ici justement se recueillir
devant la croix du sacrifice pour se
souvenir bien évidemment très bien merci
beaucoup pour ce témoignage merci alors
ta voix bien sûr la cérémonie se
poursuit c'est toujours le défilé des
combattants et on entend les afghans la
guerre en afghanistan
l'implication du canada ça a laissé des
traces quand même parce qu'il ya tous
ces jeunes vétérans qui ont quoi
aujourd'hui 40 50 ans oui le visage des
vétérans change d'une part ils
rajeunissent les vétérans d'afghanistan
sont au nombre d'environ 40000 ou si il
ya de plus en plus de vétérans alors
c'est son étude des besoins une petite
différents de ceux qui ont combattu
durant la deuxième guerre mondiale la
guerre de corée
il faut que soit réintégré au travail
après leur carrière militaire il faut
qu'il y ait un suivi psychologique alors
qu'après la deuxième guerre mondiale ce
qu'il y avait souffert de ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui le syndrome de
stress post traumatique oms nous en
occuper guerre la neurocité only
renvoyés chez eux avec très peu de
soutien maintenant on a des forces
armées canadiennes le gouvernement
canadien se rencontre on ne peut pas
bien de voir 2 du gouvernement canadien
envers ses soldats il ya un pacte sacré
vous on vous a demandé de mettre votre
vie en danger
alors on doit vous s'occuper de vous
lorsque vous êtes de retour de ces
opérations
évidemment pour les femmes qui ont servi
à la milk and aliens ya d'autres
problèmes qui s'ajoute on a encore un
reportage aujourd'hui sur justement
cette situation les femmes vivent
discrimination la misogynie du
harcèlement parfois ça peut aller
jusqu'au viol il ya quand même eu des
situations c'est quand même pas réglé la
grêle l'armée fait peut-être des efforts
il ya eu des enquêtes il y a encore une
fois il ya un vieux fond de culture
machiste qui persiste le chef d'état
major de la défense général 20 soit plus
des mesures pour que ces situations
c'est ce qui rend ce sera tolérance zéro
mais malheureusement dans le au cours
des dernières années depuis qu'en fait
que les femmes ont pu intégrer toutes
les tous les métiers de convois alors il
y en a qui ont souffert beaucoup
d'attitude de reprochable oui situation
assez difficile pour l'armée alors nos
soldats il y en a encore 1700 qui sont
déployés un peu partout certains sous
l'égide de l'otan d'autre d'autres
missions les nationaux voulions en irak
il y en a au kosovo et en ukraine aussi
après
dans les pays baltes alors un peu
partout ailleurs 1700 militaires wii qui
sont dépouillés dans des situations
parfois pas toujours facile de leur en
irak la situation reconnaît avec
l'actuel que l'irak est en turbulence
actuellement est ce qu'il va y avoir une
guerre civile alors sont dans une
situation un peu délicate alors on va
rejoindre daniel thibault qui a qui a
été témoin bien sûr de cette cérémonie
et qui a recueilli quelques témoignages
sur place daniel voilà céline ça se
termine aux annonces parle d'ailleurs on
est sur le point d'ouvrir les barrières
le long le long de la rue elgin ici pour
laisser les gens à venir porter leur
coquelicot sur sur la tempe chose
d'inconnu
ceci dit avant le début de la cérémonie
avant l'arrivée des dignitaires et j'ai
eu l'occasion avec ma collègue à senna
mon collègue stéphane d'aller d'aller me
promener parmi la foule d'aller
rencontrer des gens pour leur demander
pourquoi êtes vous ici
pourquoi c'est important d'être ici pour
vous qu'est ce que vous voulez envoyer
comme message
voici ce que ça donne
arts martiaux faire on pense aux
collègues l'accent encore là surtout qui
font du déploiement et puis c'est notre
seule chance de venir ici puisque les
passants cgt a ni jo ni le même drapeau
oui c'est important si je pense qu'on ne
connaît pas que militaire il ya de la
formation
même la formation des fois c'est
dangereux et anouk sont blessés il y en
a plusieurs qui partent sur une mission
à long terme ont pensé motus disent
adieu à leurs familles ne sachant pas la
façon qu'ils vont revenir fait pour moi
c'est la seule journée que les
anglophones et francophones on s'en fout
on viendra quelle province du canada
tout le monde se réunit ensemble comme
est fière de qu'est ce qui s'est passé
dans le poste intéressant quand même ce
commentaire c'est vrai et cette dame là
qu'il était gay d'imaginer à la crête de
vimy nous disait à quel point quand elle
se promenait sur le site avec quelques
logos canadiens que ce soit sur elle
les gens dollar était pour lui dire
merci merci transmettez sait remercier
allah ô gens chez vous c'était la
première fois elle qu'elle avait
l'occasion de venir à une cérémonie
ici à tahoua sera tout près du monument
commémoratif de guerre
alors on a parlé beaucoup de ces liens
donc avec la france la normandie en
particulier mais aussi des liens avec
les pays bas dont vous allez nous parler
à nous parler de ces bulbes de tulipes
là c'est important pour nous
voilà alors un peu un petit retour en
arrière ou en fait rentrer septembre
2019 et septembre 2020 donc ça commence
on retrouve dans cette période là on
célèbre le 75e anniversaire de la
libération des filles bas de
l'oppression nazie
rappelez-vous à l'époque et retournons
75 ans avant il ya en arrière c'était le
début de l'hiver
il y avait occupé à sion nazis dans les
pays bas on avait bloqué les transferts
de médicaments de nourriture vers les
grands centres qui fait que la famine
frappait les populations là bas bien d
ailleurs on estime qu'à quatre millions
et demi de personnes qui ont été
touchées par la famine ou dans les pays
bas 22000 personnes qui en sont morts
tous de façon directe aux ou des suites
de maladies liées à cela et à l'époque
comme il y avait rien qui pouvait entrer
il n'y avait rien qui pouvait sortir et
se sont retrouvés dans les entrepôts là
bas un nombre incalculable de bulbes de
tulipes qui sont devenu l'élément est
permis aux gens de survivre
on a consommé on a mangé les bulbes de
tulipes les hollandais le gouvernement
s'est rendu compte que ça pouvait être
une source de nutriments alors on a
publié des recettes alors ce petit bulbe
est un symbole d'amitié entre les pays
bas et le canada a été à l'époque un
élément d'un deuil un élément nutritif
pour la population ce qui leur ont
permis de passer par dessus et et à
l'époque qu'il ya 75 ans la famille
royale avaient trouvé refuge au canada
ry et avait donné cent mille bulbes de
tulipes en cadeau alors on a refait cela
on enregistrait distribué 100 mille
bulbes de tulipes qui ont été plantés
normalement en cours des dernières
semaines j'ai normalement parce que le
sol est très dur là tu as des gens qui
ont entendu et peut-être un peu tard
mais c'est une et place pour commémorer
ce 75e anniversaire anniversaire vous
allez les voir fleurir le printemps
prochain
3 bien sûr mais un peu partout à travers
le pays également
bien très intéressant tout ça merci
beaucoup daniel de votre participation
aujourd'hui merci et justement ces liens
sont tellement forts vous-même avait été
un peu hâlé fait partie un peu de ce à
quoi votre belle-famille famille était
d'origine hollandaise ont connu la
guerre mes beaux parents
et puis oui de mes beaux-parents manger
des buts de tulipes de l'autre je crois
si tu es de la betterave à sucre
chacun espérait pouvoir manger soit des
bulles de tilly pour ou de la betterave
à sucre pour changer leur ordinaire à
l'horizon réussi à passer à travers
l'hiver 44 45 dans des conditions
absolument affreuse et jusqu'à ce que
l'offensive de l'armée canadienne
reprennent et puis libère l'ensemble des
pays bas c'est là qu'on se rend compte
qu'avec l'état est comme cela qu on se
rend compte à quel point c'était dur
pour les populations civiles et marcel
humez on parle très souvent dans ces
lettres des populations néerlandaise de
ses habitants qui ont vraiment vécu mais
la famine donc c'était terrible il
voyait ces personnes aient puisé dans
les rues partout italie et c'est ça qui
est très fort chez marcel wyss et qu'il
parle des populations civiles
très vite dans ses lettres il faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui on s'intéresse de
plus en plus à ce niveau des recherches
historiques et marcel millet était
précurseur parce qu'ils avaient compris
par sa sensibilité que ces civils ce
qu'il vivait faisait partie de
l'histoire aussi de ses batailles de
l'histoire militaire est aussi
l'histoire des populations civiles
et tout cela est lié parce que les
soldats parlent avec les civils aux
échanges
well pendant qu'on voit des images de
justin trudeau qui va quitter quelques
instants justin trudeau d'ailleurs qui
sera un sommet de l'otan
très bientôt pour un cap de son ballon
et qu'elle décembre alors l'otan va
survivre
lisa sion dont emmanuel macron a dit
qu'elle était peut-être en mort
cérébrale
je crois que là il s'agirait plus le
temps a passé à travers plusieurs crises
soixante dix ans cette année c'était
l'alliance qui a permis à de conserver
les valeurs démocratiques en europe est
il par la suite d'autres a dû s'adapter
pour d'autres missions dans les balkans
en afghanistan même
pendant que le ppu 2001 alors l'otan
réussira toujours à s'adapter et puis à
faire face à ses missions
alors on se disait qu'il y avait des
airs de cérémonie un petit peu partout
dans le monde
cette année c'est à new york le
président donald trump accompagné de son
épouse magna a rendu hommage aux soldats
américains d'hyères et d'aujourd'hui
dans une cérémonie assez sobre en france
le président emmanuel macron a ravivé la
flamme sur la tombe du soldat inconnu
sous l'arc de triomphe à paris
il doit aussi inaugurer un peu plus tard
dans la journée un monument dédié aux
soldats morts lors d'opérations à
l'étranger
vous voyez c'est sur les champs elysées
et hier dimanche 10 novembre la reine a
assisté à la cérémonie du souvenir
depuis un balcon entouré par la duchesse
de cornouailles camilla parker bowles et
la duchesse de cambridge kate middleton
elles ont observé charles le prince de
galles qui accompagné de ses deux fils
william et harry
déposez les traditionnelles couronnes de
fleurs au cénotaphe à londres en
grande-bretagne également lors des
cérémonies d'hyères se tenant à douvres
les autres britanniques ont souligné
d'une façon toute particulière le jour
du souvenir en larguant depuis un
appareil datant de la deuxième guerre
mondiale
des dizaines de milliers de coquelicots
au dessus des falaises
c'est assez spectaculaire alors une
autre émission s'achève qu'est-ce que
vous souhaitez que les gens retiennent
de ces commémorations
ces paradis j'aimerais que les gens se
retiennent que ce bouillon on parle du
jour de souvenir une visite des
cérémonies spéciales mais tout au long
de l'année s'il vous plaît de grasse sud
niveau vétérans soutenir les gens qui
sont actuellement encore l'uniforme
gardé des liens étroits avec un succès
sont revenus avec quelques séquelles
encourager les demander l'heure de
parler de leurs experts
violence et non pas de garder tous à
l'intérieur d'eux-mêmes alors intégrer
la vie civile et puis remercié alors
vous qu'est ce que vous retenez c'est
quand même une cérémonie différente de
celle à laquelle vous êtes habitués
différentes mais aussi a beaucoup de
points communs comme la tombe du soldat
inconnu et beaucoup d'émotion
effectivement allez voir c'est anciens
combattants écoutez les recueillir leur
témoignage parce que je le disais avec
le temps hélas ces personnes qui ont
vécu la seconde guerre mondiale vont
nous quitter un jour donc écouter les
recueillir leur parole est aussi envie
de parler de la transmission aux jeunes
générations ça me tient vraiment très à
coeur à l'heure où les extrêmes pousse
ici et là à travers la planète
alors on se pose de nombreuses questions
et même les démocraties libérales
elle-même se pose de nombreuses
questions
eh bien allons vers ces jeunes explique
on leur ce qu'ont fait ces soldats
pourquoi ils se sont battus ces valeurs
universelles et ça je pense que c'est
l'essentiel et ces instants de
fraternité que nous vivons lors de
grandes commémorations sont les instants
clés pour ce monde de demain d'ailleurs
vous un cerf vous servez de votre livre
d'ailleurs pour faire justement pour
accompagner des jeunes leur expliquer
alors ce serait au salon du jouet de
montréal donc merci beaucoup d'avoir été
là c'est ainsi que se termine cette
émission spéciale
merci à vous tous et le téléjournal midi
suis dans un instant on se laisse sur
des images les moments les plus
marquants de ces séries
[Musique]
le chemin
dans